in and it's rebounded by embiid  simmons up the floor for the sixers  takes it all the way  and stuffs it through right now  atlanta is a half a step to a step  behind him everything is hard right now  for atlanta  all the movement it's not getting them  wide open  john collins to the bench  14-point lead for philadelphia here in  game three with a series tied at one a  piece  game four monday night and b from  simmons  yeah that was beautiful mainly because  as soon as simmons  shot whoever he is playing it doesn't  make a big difference he's using his  body here he is  finding embiid coming down right from  the top of the circle  right down the middle of the floor look  at that